the presto animation system was the work
of many people at Pixar Animation
Studios and tonight
the Academy presents a technical
achievement award to rob Jenson Thomas
Hahn George L Cora Adam Woodbury and
dirk van gelder for their contribution
[Music]
so in 2005 IDI Catmull stood in front of
all of Pixar and he announced we are
committing to build a brand new
animation system from the ground up and
he admitted that this was so difficult
that it had basically almost never been
done before and he asked for the support
of everyone at Pixar to help make it
happen so we want to thank ed and the
late Steve Jobs for believing that we
could pull it off and frankly for
supporting us when it turned out to be
way harder than any of us could possibly
have imagined to actually do it we also
want to recognize Oren Jacob Brad
Andelman and Eric Gregory who were
visionary leaders of the project from
the beginning
Kathryn serafian who is the producer of
brave who took the plunge and committed
to using presto in production and guido
Corona Steve may and Jim Morris for
their ongoing support most importantly
this is a massive effort and we share
this award with the many talented
engineers designers and also leaders
from production who designed and built
presto I want to thank my wife Diana and
all of the families of all of us and the
community of Pixar for for their support
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]